Furthermore,
if we analyze
that alcohol
that you have,
it has various various disadvantages.
It's mentioned
in the hadith of the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
by Albani.
He says that alcohol is the mother of
all evils.
And if you are drunk,
maybe you will do incest with your
mother
or with your maternal aunt or with your
paternal aunt. Our prophet said this
1400 years ago and now they're coming to
know about it.
the intoxication that is there
and there are various hadith
that talk about prohibition of alcohol.
It's mentioned in sunbaja
point number four in the book of
intoxication had number 3371.
Our beloved prophet said that alcohol
is the key to all evils.
It's mentioned in sunba maja.
Point number three,
point number four, book of intoxication
had number 3392. Anything which
intoxicates you in large quantity is
even prohibited in small quantity. No
excuse for nip or a tot. Means if you
have a large quantity of that drink. If
it intoxicates you, it is even
prohibited in small quantity. You can't
say no. Many people say I'm a social
drinker. Social drinker. ONLY ONE PEG,
TWO PEG.
I don't get intoxicated. I'm a social
drinker. Now when we do survey, you come
to know that every drunkard, every
alcoholic at one time was a social
drinker. Nobody starts drinking alcohol
to become alcoholic. He starts with
social drinker. One peg, two peg. How do
you know how much can you control? It is
addictive.
Now if you interview any social drinker
who has been drinking for several years
once or many times in his life he may
have got intoxicated. No social drinker
was drinking for many years can say
never in my life I got intoxicated. Then
he lying to you
some few times some many times. Even if
he hasn't become an alcoholic addiction
yet,
few times or many times in his life, he
may have got drunk FOR SURE. NOW IF EVEN
IF HE GETS DRUNK once in his life and
during that time
if he commits incest
or if he commits rape can he ever
forgive himself?
The damage is done. Irreversible,
irreparable. Can a good modest man
who even gets drunk once and if he
commits incest or commits rape can he
forgive himself? No. The damage is done
irre irreversible irreparable loss.
So prophet rightly said anything which
intoxicates in large quantity is even
prior in small quantity. No excuse for
nip or a tot.
It's mentioned in Maja
Maja. Point number four in the book of
intoxicants had number 3381.
The prophet says that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has cursed 10 categories of
people who are involved with alcohol.
The one who distills it. The one who
distills it for whom it is distilled.
Number one, the one who distills it.
Number two, for whom it is distilled.
Number three, the person who drinks
alcohol.
Number four, the person who transports
it. Number five, the person for whom it
is brought.
Number six, the person who sells it.
Number seven, the person who serves it.
Number 10, the person who earns from the
sale of alcohol.
Number nine, the person who buys it. And
number 10, the person who buys it for
someone else. All 10 categories of
people are cursed. That means it's a
major sin. Not only drinking alcohol is
major.
Even distilling it, even if somebody
else distills it, even serving it, even
buying it, even transporting it, buying
for somebody else. All these 10
categories Allah have cursed.